I'm gonna brush my hair before I start
this welcome to I do likes my name is
Justine and behind me you may notice a
very beautiful woman
Beyonce my girlfriend she doesn't know
it yet though I just saw this video
before I started shooting this and I am
an extremely 100% straight female but
after watching this video
this is Beyonce in a summer campaign for
hmm and only tell you what I haven't
actually been to H&M in a while but let
me tell you where I'm gonna be going
tonight I'm goin H&M this next if it
wasn't actually new but my sister just
sent me yesterday and I almost peed
myself for watching it it's a cat riding
on a Roomba chasing a duck I mean this
combination is thing that you just don't
even dream of other than Beyonce
prancing around on a beautiful beach
looking amazing but duck this is a
recipe for success and I know a thing or
two about recipes like don't bail oh
sorry I forgot I was shooting an episode
heater moving on to Tekken games
semester you guys know I'm obsessed with
vine but I finally just got a new phone
because my front-facing camera was
broken so if you're not following me on
vine no juice no search for iJustine and
you will find me draw something hello
has released draw something to which is
absolutely an incredible upgrade from
draw something one there's so many new
tools there's a sparkle pen there's a
ammo pen there are animal print pens I
think it's gone too far to be completely
honest with you because I have a pretty
tech savvy person and when I was
scrolling through here I was like I just
want to drive I give me a freaking
pencil like what is this let me know
what you guys think the new Draw
Something and are there any other cool
apps that you guys have been using I
want to know last but not least style
and fashion
it's someone fashion because I went
through and deleted all of my old
t-shirts on my Spreadshirt store and
added all the new ones we're also
working on some new designs but if you
guys want to check them out and get
yourself a t-shirt go do I just need
enough Spreadshirt calm and get yourself
a shirt if you have some sort of
iJustine merchandise make sure you guys
take a picture or post video of it on
vine and i'm gonna make a little collage
of some of you guys be sure to hashtag
wearing IJ I'll probably post something
on my blog or Instagram or tumblr I
don't know there are so many social
networking sites that it's honestly it's
getting out of control I mean there's
just too many and I want to be on all of
them and I want to use them all but
there's just not enough time today I'll
see you guys in the next episode
watching likes and in the meantime I'm
gonna go and watch Beyonce don't forget
to like this video don't forget to
subscribe
I've got some watching to do I just
can't shake it like her man